how are you DP I'm good let me start
with the weather forecast
please skies are clearing some sunshine
this afternoon should be a beautiful
night for for football
okay and it's can you give me the
traffic because I usually get that with
my weather dance looks like it's busy
it's congested okay okay it is game day
so what do you expect tonight Dan I I'm
serious what the Patriots do with
Edelman's position
can you put James White in there at
times is is this Amendola is it Hogan do
they create something different
you got Gronk back it's been a while
since we've seen him but I'm more
interested in Kansas City their
secondary you got a couple of Pro
Bowlers there
Houston's back he's healthy now for
missing last year a good portion of that
but I'm also interested in Alex Smith
probably more than anything because is
he different this year can he be
different this year
Patrick mahomes look pretty good you
know that he's the guy in waiting and
what's Belichick do with Tyreke Hill or
Travis Kelce because normally he takes
away your best weapon well what's your
best weapon that's a toss-up between
those two the Kansas City is more
interesting to me tonight and the
ringling is well on I heard your your
Super Bowl prediction on your show
yesterday Dan you and I have the same
team winning the Super Bowl I am
lockstep with you with Seattle but I do
think New England is the team that faces
them that we're gonna see a rematch of
Super Bowl xlix and you believe it's the
Steelers what what about the I guess
that I guess the Patriots are you not
sold on a repeat AFC performance I think
it's hard to repeat and I know that
they're the last team to do it but
talking to Rodney Harrison about it he
said Belichick never brought up the
Super Bowl winning the Super Bowl
repeating his Super Bowl champs you know
they certainly have the mindset the
toughness they got better in the
offseason it's just it's it's weird how
things happen and sometimes you go how
did that happen why did that happen
it just feels I look at Pittsburgh and
you know maybe I'm wishing for a
different story
but I also
look at there's there's no other team
that has a quarterback running back wide
receiver group like Pittsburgh does but
that's the best trio in the NFL in my
opinion can the defense be good can
those young you know defensive back step
up you know JJ Watts brother's going to
step in for James Harrison a you know
it's it I I think Pittsburgh has learned
it took a long time but I think they're
learning what they need to do the
question is are you able to do that can
you put that in play and win a game on
the road could you win in Foxborough you
know the Ravens are the only team that's
capable doing that at least the the the
old Ravens not the reincarnation but I
look at Pittsburgh and say can Ben play
well on the road and if he does then I
like the Steelers this year yeah it's
not just I guess there's two options I
guess either play well on the road or
play well enough in the regular season
to make Tom Brady get on a plane to come
play you and I just have a feeling that
the Raiders of the team that has that
best opportunity in the AFC to do that
what do you think about the Raiders 2017
shot here DP they were my surprise team
last year I thought they would make the
leap there's always one or two teams and
you know the Titans or the team I feel
like can do that this year but I look at
the Raiders and I bet secondaries
terrible I love car they they have
skilled position players but I think
they take a step back I think Dallas and
the Raiders take a step back I think I
think both teams overachieved last year
and I thought this even before Elliott
was suspended I just it feels like
there's a couple of teams they'll hit
the reset and then they're you know if I
look at the division that that AFC West
is tough San Diego is going to be a good
team they'll be a fun exciting team
there you got Denver who might be the
worst team in the division which is
saying a whole lot Kansas City is going
to be good I don't know if I think it'll
be tougher sledding for for Oakland than
people think dan Patrick joining me here
from Foxborough prior to tonight's
season kickoff on NBC with Al crest Dan
and the gang at 8:30 is when things kick
off with toe meets ball when do you
begin your show dan I think the
sensitivity started 7:30 okay I think
it's an hour pregame show and then we we
turn it over to Alan Chris okay and then
who's who's the musical act are you
gonna be out there in the front row with
a with a lighter and and doing that I
don't I don't I think I don't think
there's a musical act there isn't
I don't think which is good you know I'm
fine with just having a football I don't
know come on I don't need to have a
musical interlude here to get me ready
for a football I know that that's not
for me
it's it's for the fan on the periphery
or maybe you know somebody who doesn't
normally watch but then we'll watch to
see Taylor Swift or Dave Matthews or
whatever it might be or Dierks Bentley
I'm okay with just seeing football I'm
alright with ten more Rascal Flatts
Brown Band whatever I know what's the
last concert you've been to was the last
one you've been to I went to a band see
a band called twiddle okay any more meat
on those bones - what do you who's
twiddle and where where did Jared I am
ban and almost in the the form sound of
fish okay Dave Matthews kind they
they're they're kind of new onto the
scene but I just saw them last week okay
and let's see the last concert hmm I'm
hoping to go see Sturgill Simpson if
you're familiar with Simpson you're
going deep you're going deep down the
dogs chart here yeah yeah I can't go to
the big concerts I don't like going in
and with 20,000 and my closest friends
I'd like seeing a little bit smaller
okay intimate
yeah concert yeah but um you know I'm
open to I'm open to seeing you know if
you got any suggestions Here I am a guy
who once went to Britney Spears by
himself now say well I'm whoa
oh that's rifle I've heard you tell that
story on your show yeah okay and and I
had a night off and I got a ticket to
see Britney Spears I actually had two
tickets couldn't find anybody to go with
me so the beer lines weren't long at all
[Laughter]
I can actually walk during a song get
back get a beer and come back and the
song is still be playing so that'll give
you night yeah no but but at least I
think a lot of people though I'd never
watch that or I'd never listen to that
I'd rather experience it and say all
right I got to see that you got a story
you got a story to tell
I'm so so if you if you so if you like
smaller venues then maybe James Dolan's
band would be good for you JD in the
strike him I would go see I try to go
see Woody Allen play in his yeah
ensemble years ago but yeah I the the
fun shows of the small shows in my
opinion when you get too big that that's
not it's just not intimate it's a bit
loses a little bit of that before we are
let DP go into that New England day
Chris do you want to ask him to our poll
question to do on the Rich Eisen show oh
please do that yeah Dan did you hear the
news that miles Garrett might be out a
few weeks for Cleveland yeah who's the
most cursed safe franchise in sports
gonna go Browns Clippers or all of the
Atlanta teams together we just we're
just just throwing them all Maj fitting
all the Atlanta sports teams together
dad um I don't I don't know if the
Clippers are cursed anymore it feels
like the Browns are there and usually
the punch line or the bottom line is I
suppose the Browns so when I saw the
Garrett was injured and I go to insist
the Browns if he played for somebody
else he wouldn't miss any time but he
plays for the Browns you just go yeah
it's the Browns yeah I would think
although the Jets are you know sneaking
up there too you know they're they're
putting in there their claims for being
a bad bad franchise and then the mix are
in there too I would probably look at
the mixes the and they're not cursed
they're just the most mismanaged yeah
well that could be a curse in itself to
and you could say that about the Jets I
mean you know I we were talking about
putting the Indians in there too but
it's tough to put a team that's won 14
straight games in a row
second straight year in that mix right
now but and by the way who did the Jets
just picked up Jeremy Kerley Jermaine
Kearse Oh see that's next level I was
about to ask you another question damn
but that's a walk-off I can I can I mean
I just drop my phone but I'd you know
like you drop the mic but I don't want
to break no no all right we'll just put
a button on it and say thanks for
calling in DP the whole chance all right
okay
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy